what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation I am rejoined by Aaron the Alexander
Aaron how are you I am doing fantastic Greg
I am ready to watch this James Gunn movie
debut this is his first movie it's his first
movie yeah we thought we'd watch this before
he ruins the DC Universe ruins Superman that's
gonna be fun I'm excited for his DC Universe
and it's gonna be like a fun little game to
see like oh this actor has carried on in the
James Gunn Pantheon of films blah blah blah
here he's in those early earmarks you see
some Michael Rooker probably probably yeah
is he in this I I imagine anyway guys you
know it's a deal please go ahead and leave
a like on this video and be sure to subscribe
and click the notification on because we are
covering so many movies here on the Chanel
I hear this movie is uh YouTube I hear there's
a lot of a lot of craziness in this film and
uh just know that you know none of it's real
all right just know that YouTube it's not
gonna hurt you as always full-length region
watch along where you sync up with your own
copy available for all of our super sexy rejects
that was a lot of patrons and thank you to
all who've been joining our patreon page it
is one of the blessings of the reject Nation
also covers several things exclusive their
reaction Heights Watch Dogs included let's
get
to it
a meteor a floating turd this might be the
only James got movie I haven't seen too really
yeah wow
even super that's fun I've seen super yeah
Ripper will flies about 27 miles an hour I'd
have thought more like 32
[Laughter] normally I didn't fill in tell
you exactly how fast it's going within two
miles per hour it's fascinating he looks so
young I was just thinking about Babyface Nathan
um what a great capture the juxtaposition
yeah okay Monster cam will Sam Rainey dead
sounds like a little
pulse in there that was a really well constructed
opening with capturing the small town flare
right up front with this Larger than Life
entity coming here it's Global threat yeah
yeah the contrast yeah [Music]
oh this guy's a great actor [Music] I look
so familiar from hey I'll do it mayor
live life to the fullest Darwin said fittest
things in this movie what the hell we're smarter
but we're neophytes the Cockroach that fellow's
been around 300. oh my God teenagers which
of us is the more successful species that
is the question of the movie is that James
Gunn oh [__] yeah
recognize him behind there's Michael Rucker
hey there he is yup free white-haired white
bearded gun
I know what he wants to borrow I don't see
like an abusive husband
's mother left her daddy's a drunk she's 17
years old old Grandpa's up big old Cadillac
I don't know what an authentic accent is but
that sounds authentic I believe them damn
Michael Rooker was cut ripped Rucker
oh man even sweet he looks so creepy yeah
because I said he got her when she was 17.
why don't you just work one out for yourself
though
I'm just not in the mood okay tail it's so
uncomfortable yeah yeah when the hell are
you in the morning [Music] where's he going
where are you going out for walk he's salty
I know all there is to know about the cross
this feels for some reason I keep flashing
a peacemaker you know like the vibe of this
I can just figure of comparing it to like
modern day James Gunn yeah yeah this feels
like something that would happen in that for
sure yeah especially this scene right here
[Music] yep it goes back to the apartment
she's a weird alien my sister Megan she was
a big fat old cow and I'd be thinking is he
seeing her that ain't me you couldn't been
more than 10 or 11. hell that was game cheater
creepy cheater
listen to the bird it's a warning sign the
crow knows the crows always know
oh
damn okay
I can't don't do it she just won't worry about
me
you're gonna have to explain how you found
this thing
oh Trail
I don't know I'm just not the kind of guy
who would follow the trail I'm good yeah get
the hell out of there I get curious to try
to watch this from as far of a distance I
would take my camera and try to see as far
as it can go and then I'm going to call someone
if you like you should look into this yeah
don't on come on so that wouldn't be me no
way hell no I'm out ah nope nope nope
[Music]
it's so gross
whoa what X-ray vision x-ray vision it's the
last thing I expected to see oh God in his
throat on his brains make it over okay white
people love to go to the woods bro this couldn't
couldn't be me couldn't be me hey Middle Eastern
people sometimes go to amateur and black people
who it is
a little nose that's where I would it's good
that'll no thank you
how fun it has the if it has a flare of like
a whole bunch of other horror movies already
Evil Dead alien little Predator yeah definitely
a little predator for sure x-ray vision and
stuff the thing I've never seen it but I'm
I'm sure
meat Feast mate gotta eat that mate Telltale
sign that you're corrupted when you eat it
raw [Laughter]
God Elizabeth Banks is just so unattractive
gross even today repulsive she's so gross
I don't even I can't stop looking I can't
stop looking at energy laughs
uh what is he doing throwing into the leaves
it's getting comfy make himself a little nest
oh oh now she wants to play the seduction
game now she's in the mood now he used the
guilt card does that work [Laughter] put guilt
in defense fail proof [Laughter]
that's awesome oh my God I just slept cut
back to her so I could see how gross she is
so does this like prey on its most Primal
senses to the extreme bloodlust sexual loss
yes or no find out he seems more confused
and turned on are you crying is he he's sad
oh he's conflicted because the monster wants
to kill her but he loves his wife don't do
that oh it's gonna Slither in your mouth
oh God I don't like it I think he's gonna
slow their thinner
nope hey what's this I don't want it not not
one bit it's just little bug bud that could
be fleas
checked out there eh
[Laughter]
it's been a while [Music] laughs
so how co-workers talk I think so yeah always
calling the woman who come here that use
I'm telling you this morning us it's a real
changing Grant you can say something like
that Nate me how to Mr Grant me oh hey there
give me a couple of your rib eyes how many
you need eight [Laughter] give me 14. you're
having a party a little surprise for the wife
damn
baby where are our savings I thought Nathan
Fillion would be the main character right
you think so or maybe it's just like the opening
too until interesting structure so far right
right it's all busted up
[Laughter]
the body horror that you could feel is just
building yeah the impending doom of the body
horror a little bit of the fly as well
someone I've never seen
oh don't eat that dog is he gonna eat the
dog he's gonna eat Skipper oh does it turn
you into just like always keep saying meat
so it's like turn your neck of the cannibals
and stuff yeah don't pop it oh God this is
gonna pop some [__] I can't take a pimple
dude no way no freaking way oh there's gonna
be some fun makeup designs
turn around so I could see how repugnant you
are [Laughter]
oh no these sounds the the sound designs yeah
gross especially we have headphones on right
reaps into the ears uh what the hell James
Gunn I could have just blurred this on YouTube
[Laughter] cowards clearly he thought she
was gross too yeah whoa
[Music] oh what is going on I don't like it
oh God that was unexpected I thought this
[__] like this would happen way later
right wasn't those fleshy Cheeto was that
sentient Cheeto puff
oh wants to mate with her and it's rawest
he's conflicted yeah the human in him is still
there
I gotta go to work
I will never understand there's a black guy
grown man two two of them two black people
winning this town she's saying what it used
to be man
never seen trauma but I understand the reference
yep
we actually got to open every door I am dead
it's good at playing creepy that's his main
trick
oh does humble have feelings for her I think
he does what you doing oh nothing just I'm
trying to get a buzz on but I can't I can't
do buff got too much muscle mass I don't know
what it is I'm too strong with all these muscles
it's interesting seeing him play a more relatable
guy instead of cocky douchebag you know it's
usually right just the smart-ass wise guy
yeah it's kind of chilly tonight yeah
yeah oh he's not just talking about the the
skyline he's talking about this hideous woman
here
like Thomas right
she's conflicted I have a husband
oh he's gonna totally Slaughter this one oh
he's gonna kill the poop out of her try not
to cuss ing [Laughter] over the fish in the
sea and over the birds of the air and over
every living thing that a baby with tomato
ah there's a bit of an atom quality is it
tomato or an apple
Tomatoes Tomatoes I was confused even if it
wasn't Apple why do you go to baby an apple
no no no no no no no no no no ready to see
this I don't want to I'm ready to see this
it's not ready oh I'm not ready you're gonna
kill it oh no nope
this is disturbing poor baby and woman of
course where does it feed it's gonna go in
her belly oh it's so gross that was disgusting
no not the not this thing not the pokey poke
[Music]
I hate this this is really gross
what's it's like a succubus what's it what's
it feeding on is it feeding off or is it going
inside I think it's putting more of itself
into her okay [Music] [Laughter] foreign
[Laughter] that's so bad that's so messed
up dark twisted humor man
[Music]
there's this Vibe about this movie that feels
like a classic you went to Blockbuster and
just picked it randomly off the shelf kind
of uh yeah like we're gonna watch this on
a Friday night whoa oh my God baby what happened
to your face it's just a beast
yeah the makeup is wild we gotta get you to
the hospital no no no no I already saw Dr
Carl he said things like this happen really
no look a bit like that performance is really
good in this movie you see his conflict you
feel the suffering within him as well yeah
oh you felt that changing him huh
[Music] Roscoe he's eating the dogs she was
able to put it together it's all connected
[Music] oh she's morphing into something
oh what is she turning into you see that it's
not turning into there's a lower half there's
something off of her lower half yeah I see
it do you know what Brenda Gutierrez no her
eyes are so blue girl disappeared Friday night
signs of a struggle in the house people saw
Grant going into her house oh God it must
have been someone that looks like Grant yeah
Grant has a lot of very distinguishable creepy
figures about his face give me a call as soon
as he gets you
I do like the writing of how we get to know
the characters just through the interactions
they have not about like laying down a bunch
of backstory or something oh yeah the subtext
of it yeah well written and directed successful
for a reason foreign
never go in the basement you've not seen any
horror movie oh is it gonna be a bunch of
dead dogs I want to see that if that's the
case
and that's what I call a hell no
oh
damn oh oh God that isn't worse than what
I thought it would be oh that's so disturbing
[Music] oh my God damn Jesus this is so violent
yeah yeah I don't think they just they'd do
that in a movie today
oh please go back and he's gone right now
please do it please do it oh [Music]
[Music] a huge house oh come on why are you
running for me baby
now it's like a domestic Thriller I can't
trust you no more
oh my God it's never not gross
[Applause] his arm is becoming old whoa It's
all slithery that's the word whoa he's a tentacle
arm what the hell
oh man that was wild wow wow now we're cooking
oh it really it does a great job with that
like old school B movies sci-fi alien schlock
yeah oh three days later and especially with
having that sign at the beginning of the movie
with the specific uh billboard and the the
way the music is done too it's definitely
throwback for sure we need to find this grant
I mean yesterday Town Council lit a Roman
Candle stuck it up my ass Jack your leisure
activities ain't my business now he's the
main character yeah that's interesting that's
a really interesting structure she heard you
say squid she's going to go out and create
a guy
today Bill ah Jenna Fisher his ex-wife oh
is this when they were married they were together
while she was in the office you said it was
dark you don't know what the hell you saw
his arm was all bendy mayor well it's obvious
guy Lyme disease yeah that's it that makes
you look like a squid another attack over
at the cast of bets she's playing a reception
that's good yeah
it's what you know two nights ago a mayor
was stolen from this property owned by if
it's given that Rancher with the cleft palate
yeah your mom weren't too proud when you came
out neither Wally
had our next is going to end up here a family
called The Strip Myers we're gonna have to
go there tonight Lalo and wait what's going
get that son of a [__] sheep Mr Pibb extra
oh this music it's straight out of Predator
okay from them jokers wanted to use it we
should be all right before we go ah we're
using the third act baby let's go third at
grenade it's cool this movie like transitions
into different types of alien sci-fi horror
movies yeah take a love letter to a different
ones it interweaves throughout yeah how unless
you bring Grant back alive your only chance
of doing that is with me bring her she's the
main supporting character you guys have to
fall in love she has to come
thank you for these guys next victims I guess
okay good I want those little girls to die
there's Jack I want you all to stay inside
tonight you're here I would love to go to
the South I feel like we'd fit right we would
be highly welcome
especially when the Sun goes down yeah man
especially you oh yeah dude oh my God it's
your favorite love me yeah not time we're
kids you came knocking on my window in the
middle of that oh he remembers so well vividly
my sister what the hell you doing out there
she says if she's going to run away to Hollywood
and be a big star so she says she needs a
bodyguard and invites me to come along and
I said Starlight oh dude you missed your chance
you could take care of herself I think it's
you she looks like a floating head [Laughter]
she'll fit in great with that kid from Thor's
love and thunder and Ezra Miller and Flash
from the get-go he's so [__] [__]
up our Fame unfortunately you floating head
some [__] look at a sincere kind guy perfect
time to head on her when you're on your her
husband's a murdering Rampage right clean
in what has he morphed into where are you
evolution is much bigger than I thought I
love good makeup man
[__] let's cut its head off what are we
gonna do now bill cuffs won't even fit on
them
third grade alive this is concerned can't
handcuff him because it won't even fit on
him
we'll get the car all slimy
same bill or Dale forgot I don't know one
of them one of them I'll tell you what Hank
God damn it Bobby France whoa oh good nasty
damn they really put him in that makeup right
I don't know how long that took we're just
here take you to get some help right now that
is insane that mouth to like the prosthetic
mouth transition it's actually making my stomach
a little queasy that rarely happens oh God
it's making me hungry it feels turned inside
out hungry oh it actually is really uh hibachi
[Laughter] that is truly gross yeah you say
you don't want to eat that no stop right there
you son of a [__] you're dead we need
to find that girl now you can make his peaceful
or you can make it hard that's all I got that
guy shot right there that guy lying
[Laughter]
I love the way how it's realized yeah oh James
Gunn please come back to horror man stuck
true to that I know this makes me go produce
that Swamp Thing movie man right right
you afraid it's like way in the back easy
for you to say back there uh he's the one
I identify with the most [Laughter] yeah he's
not gonna be dead oh no wow what a great title
it is literally the verb to describe boy and
it moves that's that's a great title yeah
and also it describes like the texture I love
a good title love a good title man very fitting
oh no what has she morphed into I was just
thinking of the same thing
don't be a sore loser great little character
trait I love those little nuances my question
is who's the one black dude who's not a cop
that's with him I've never addressed it
oh no no I did not expecting I'm sorry the
years oh Jesus oh I hate it I hate it so much
what the [__]
ah
no one seeing me like this oh my god oh no
what is happening Brenda [Music]
get the get out of there just go I'm so I'm
so [__] hungry
I never knew anyone could be so hungry what
oh my God that that possum over there oh God
yep yep that black guy should have some sense
too you need to get out of there bro we better
get you to the hospital right quick Hospital
you're in a hospital bill shut up [Music]
nope nope
[Laughter]
It's Gonna Pop oh no no no no
oh the bastard let us here oh my God
whoa what is that what is that [Music]
no no no no no no no no cover your mouth
no no put your mouth on Earth what are you
doing what are you doing what are you doing
I hate this I hate this I hate this I hate
this
no no no no no no no no no no no no
wow how did you guys all survive oh my God
he's lying he's just trying to act like yeah
no no the other one's died instantly alien
wised up no alien toy got in him
oh no it's gonna Slither in somebody's bath
oh it's like that Friday the 13th maybe not
forever on the street I haven't seen those
either
wait who's she I want to see more of her
she's a brand new oh this movie is so smart
honey you're gonna turn into a plum in there
prune mama I know what turns into what so
once you finish up in there and get yourself
into bed you're here is this movie gonna suggest
where it goes oh God or it slithers into is
that what they're gonna do I think it is Somewhere
Out There Kevin foggy was like this guy should
make Guardians of the Galaxy
man clearly has a vision
Goosebumps this has that Goosebumps flare
totally it's hitting it's hitting all the
checks right now
going to her vagina oh God
dude I was joking this no we're actually gonna
do this please God don't do it
[Music]
that's mean
get it out get it out get it out get it out
thank you oh we can see the whole history
of the worlds it's conquered oh it's like
a high of mine right did not expect to get
that
this is like the movie We just watched
oh is that easy to kill it oh never mind you
injured it I think yeah burn that [__]
burn it yeah cook him cook him hahaha [Music]
[Music] no you're not gonna kill the kids
I know you're not about to kill them I think
they should kill the kids
[Music]
good movie Kill the kids that's what you do
established whoa yeah you're screwed get out
of there girl jump out the window okay heat
can hurt them so they need like actual fire
torches
you didn't break your legs wow you really
know how to fall young she drinks milk high
calcium strong bones
the keys of course you don't got the damn
Keys you gotta learn how to hotwire real quick
wow what a cool shot it's swallowing you alive
all right you three get these folks out of
the bar and all the rotten stance you can't
be doing them any good you take this I got
my coat
there's always been an ensemble filmmaker
hasn't he I think so you're gonna Slither
on the deer too it's goddamn biological weapons
that's what it is government Wheels you know
why because I don't take no [__] from
nobody that does stay here they want to kiss
my ass how'd this guy become mayor
James Gunn was onto something ahead of his
time marriage
it's a second my mind just like you say oh
it's a real hive mind I'm sorry for trying
to strangle you know I lost my head or it's
just one being afraid you wouldn't love me
no more
quite you better set back down you don't look
so good hey oh it's getting worse by the second
sir it's the full-on zombie movie right now
she has a point just like open it come on
love the depraved nature of these characters
[Applause]
what is that yeah
is it acid oh foreign
don't hesitate shoot this Slither too
well [__] [Music]
is there no way to save them once they infect
them or you can never get it out I'm gonna
guess maybe if you tickle them maybe that'll
get it out they hate tickling shock them sweat
it out maybe you could like sweat it out put
them in a sauna or something yeah
oh business as usual yeah
he's gonna come with me hey damn
from that one body of one consciousness of
that one alien okay friends are still out
there Trevor
the heck is going on I love the choice where
he really watches his he does like the childish
swearing it says like dang it darn it heck
[Laughter]
oh damn she's Gotten Good at murdering right
that'll get her done
Jesus I think my question is I guess we have
to wait till the finale but what value did
adding this other character bring to the film
thanks
man after all that murder and she still looks
like not sweating no blood repulsive and no
I have such fiends of contempt for her looks
but
I need you to get the CDC on the horn for
me okay I'll get you right back Tree in her
front yard where it's got in his pipes it
messes with the whole system on with me you
took a big [__] don't you lie oh oh oh
[Music] God I'm gonna fall into your mouth
James Gunn putting his ex-wife and stuff a
habit he will never repeat yeah
oh yep that's her value in the story because
she saw the the hive mind oh yes she's the
only Survivor to see it
this is Jack or it's a general term meaning
outer space [__] oh
now he's here but the fire stopped this love
spreads grows absorbing the minds and bodies
of the organisms around it
if I worry about [__] in my pants I'd
be fascinated you were just like teaching
a class that kind of pertains to the situation
at hand here Shelby did you get the CDC for
me we're at the city limits welcome back killer
[Music] watch out
oh this should be such a great excuse to kill
everyone you know what I mean totally finally
wipe the towel clean from all these annoying
people wipe away the race to start a new
at least she's safe she's the chosen one
we're the Guardians when you need them [Music]
it's black different man we had a few hey
I mean the preference when they go to church
and congregate and all that and they're listening
to a black that means this town is not a racist
I'm sure only a few people have a problem
themselves [Laughter]
I wonder why it is all the best conflict movie
directors start with either thriller or horror
movies oh that's a deer
I think so it's a weird looking deer oh you're
screwed if you got bit you're infected
that's a fascinating design
she's Brave now
yeah Grenade third at grenade we gotta go
oh once one sees us they all see us really
it was obvious but I called it
is our Queen most protect our Queen yeah they're
dragging these bodies too Lord you think that'll
lead us to Miss Grant don't you Now where's
James Gunn and all this did he get slithered
on or is he chilling at home somewhere I probably
got slurred on I'm not hoping they kill her
off kill the wife off yeah do they have the
balls too it'd be a pretty bold move oh yeah
where'd they put him or is this the feeding
ground I hear some weird noises probably means
you're gonna get eight homie
don't you look at me like that
It's gotta be like a king and a queen right
like I'm taking it that's the case
we're screwed yep so interesting so he's the
only other person besides the girl in the
beginning to get the direct tentacles so what's
gonna happen to him
I do like how they realize that the Korean
personalities there's kind of like a Texas
Chainsaw Massacre vibe to them the queen personality
yes it's like super excuse bile all the time
very angry and sensitive
see not morphing into anything I think he
is morphing he's gonna eat her
oh we just gave it in okay
oh damn you're like a shrine to her
oh man oh God that is a wild design ah it's
horrifying it's kind of like a centipede of
sorts yeah it's coming out of the house damn
there's a worm heads that's where they're
bringing the bodies track the bodies on the
floor Drive the bodies on them that's where
they're joining together
oh gross
how icky
well now that is some dumb [__] you got
that right
[Music]
how emotionally volatile the creatures are
not to go through some adjustments after all
these changes what is it exactly huge job
decorating baby
no you don't want to hurt me Grant you like
being called Grant there is a strange tragedy
to this character yeah I felt that from the
beginning
you don't have to be alone we could be together
I never had much use for this world anyway
it's got eyes and ears everywhere while you
do what you need to do because it's your nature
don't kiss don't kiss
just shot him in the face you stab him in
the face you wouldn't have had that happen
I would have gone for the eyeball
kill me party please
[__] [__]
how long do they have before it goes where
the hell the feathers come from what the hell
dude Jesus underhand underhand ah no oh no
I love that subvert those expectations
a whole ass couch
it's pretty wild that they've did all this
this is gonna look like the ending of peacemakers
oh no
oh God he's finishing [Music]
after the tent to go there's like there's
really creepy sexual undertones yeah yeah
good thing happens propane
that was convenient yeah
[Music] oh no is it gonna kill him too
gross cover your mouth
it's a whole lot better yep naturally the
hive mind Falls there's a whole dead ass Town
only two of you all survived the sexual deviant
qualities you're just like that's so unsettling
to me it's like just like things you just
really get under your skin I feel morally
compromised right now of course she's fine
she had a couch to block her from the explosion
Holding Out for a Hero to the end of the night
come on move faster
no way
I live now you live with him you need both
of them things and you to get all woomy oh
that's awesome yeah oh this is awesome just
moving on she's moving on might as well he's
dead man you got to repopulate this town
Bishop Bill's just a few miles down the tent
at that hospital there with the green stupid
thing up top if the hospital's still up and
running now one of the aliens have time to
board up the windows
surprise he never made a sequel to this one
maybe he didn't make enough money but that's
probably yeah that's likely well they have
called it the slithering Slither the slither
slithers slithers is a plural two Slither
to Slytherin
uh it's Slytherin Slither live Slither too
um Slither on Slither Slither Origins
Slither Resurrection Slither Resurrection
Slither Generations is good
Slither ending explained breakdown Easter
eggs how it should have slithered
I watched Slytherin 0.25 speed and here's
what I found honest slithers
Slither pitch
what a cool ending shot they're still walking
it's still going hold it hold it
wow what's gonna happen out of the town everything's
going to be prosperous you think it's going
to find its footing again I mean there's a
lot of land they could uh there's a lot of
commercial you know right a lot of real estate
potential is what I'm getting at a lot of
real estate this can now become a tourist
attraction they can make money from the people
that died you know profit on their Advance
what I would do if I was in their situation
right now considered in fact there's a lack
of surveillance is go through everyone's pockets
and try to just grab as much money as you
can right no I'm talking about like just diamonds
jewelry nothing that's like checking account
credit cards like like cash or cold cash that
way uh that that's what I would do at least
in a situation like how many how many mattresses
full of cash do you think you're just in that
town oh God there's got to be at least one
person there who's like oh they've been living
amongst a small town but they made their living
off of being like a drug dealer or something
and they probably have oh loads again the
mayor probably has so much corrupt money just
lying around much Mr Pibb so much Mr pip too
yeah Mr PIV for days yeah there's a lot a
lot of ways that you could take advantage
of the situation true I get uh I'd probably
take all the cash yeah do you think there's
a post credit scene there might be I don't
know it's an early gun who knows oh there
is there will be let's wait let's let's wait
for let's just skip to it all right we're
gonna escape to it [Music] Goosebumps The
Girl Who Cried Monster the girls scared me
okay inspiration
[Music]
wow they're doing post credit scenes back
then huh oh brain
no no it lives not the cat it's a kitty cat
I was looking at they trained the cat to lick
it that's mean what's with the animal abuse
I don't know James's gonna have something
against animals clearly
Jesus Christ man back off the animals gun
the Superman movie's gonna be full of like
she's gonna murder crypto the dog right four
seconds yeah
yeah right it also use some live ones too
what's the deal man what's the dealio what's
your problem James gone God you like it I
did I had a lot of fun I had a lot of fun
with that that was better than I was expecting
I've heard nothing but good things but it
exceeded my expectations too it exceeded your
expectations yeah because I really truly expected
it to be like a [__] four dollar film
really yeah I don't know well this is his
first film so I thought he had like a low
low budget I didn't I knew I had a feeling
Michael Rucker would be in it but I didn't
know about the other stars but yeah I thought
it was a lot of fun I thought it was very
cleverly constructed that it clearly has a
lot of love for horror films of the past it
used tropes that we're familiar with it's
averted some other tropes the effects and
the practice the visual effects and the Practical
effects were both incredible uh for the time
and for now that's right right visual it's
like the okay VFX I know stuff uh it was good
it was like makeup effects makeup effects
yeah I thought the acting was really good
I thought that I had a good I don't know I
really enjoyed the way that Michael Rucker
was able to play with both playing this creepy
character but also was able to show like the
monster side of it it was there was there
was Nuance in his performance and this alien
possession thing and it was just an enjoyable
film overall it had some really disturbing
things it was surprisingly funny and yeah
it it's interesting seeing the start of where
gun kind of took off from and what we know
him to be today with the Guardians film with
things like Peacemaker and and Suicide Squad
yeah and yeah dude it was really dope yeah
I like the I like the portrayal of Michael
rooker's character a lot because it seems
whatever this creature is bonds because like
becomes in symbiosis with the with the actual
personality of the character yeah you know
it's and like it was took off because like
the way they handled Michael rooker's introduction
here has been just a normal person he he really
did love his wife like he really did love
her even when he was like tempted to cheat
he actually didn't go through like she jumped
on him and then it was like a second later
like I can't yeah you know and even and they
clearly established like this guy's been because
they're setting you up like ah he's just like
a really horny guy or something you know he's
super he's just a horn dog and he's a he's
a creep and he's Michael Rooker so you know
we know that's what Michael Rooker is probably
in real life too that's why he always plays
these people because he's a pervert Oriole
this is a nasty human being here that's why
he always plays nasty people can't trust that
guy I would never want to be around Michael
Rooker I don't think I would
there's just something about it it's just
like I don't know you give me the tingles
man there's nothing about you I just feel
like I have my penis would shriveled around
you so you're gonna do something to me so
I'm supposed to hug you man I don't know I
don't know I just feel like it's like listen
son because he's like yeah I couldn't do it
man
um she's a really creepy guy it's a big deal
the reason is always playing creepy people
um but she's good he's really good so I thought
the setup of him was really well orchestrated
because he I thought it was going to go a
more cliche path like ah he was going to have
this affair and because of the affair that's
how he found the alien but now they took a
very different approach and weirdly enough
when he the more he morphs into an alien it
might be the time that's hardest for him uh
because he's got a truly cap because Michael
Rooker has that ability to be very off-putting
for the creepy ways be simultaneously Charming
while being creepy but then also just this
great depth of sadness in his eyes yeah you
know and you really needed that for the monster
portrayal uh at the very end I like the way
that was realized so it was kind of a neat
structure to start it off where it's so much
about him in the First Act when he's really
the the villain of the story you know and
there's a and it has this combined tragedy
of the character uh I thought it was really
that was really weird how they did that structure
is my only recollection of anything from this
movie was like a commercial that I remember
Nathan phillian being in it so I just assumed
he was the lead um and then he's nowhere near
as interesting of a character is that I mean
these are the most interesting characters
oh yeah yeah like by a long shot uh like maybe
the feelings charming and he's good he's serviceable
I think I think everyone's good I think everyone's
really good and they're all very fitting and
they bring their personalities to life uh
but yeah I didn't I wasn't very uh I think
what James Gunn has evolved as a writer and
a director is that while doing crazy intricate
plots is getting you to really root for them
uh for this characters on the on the emotional
Journey they have to go on as well yeah you
know specifying his uh Ensemble and the characters
we're following I feel like this one is very
much Michael Rooker was like the lead in The
First Act of the story but then for the most
part everything after that became about the
event itself itself and these are just the
the vehicles in which we're following this
story within the small town exactly and he's
he's really Gotten Good at having both strong
characters and strong plots yeah because this
film is all about this is mainly about the
immediacy of the situation and and like I
thought I did a really good job on the like
it was gross it was mainly gross it was it
wasn't violence I wouldn't call it scary no
I wouldn't call it suspenseful but I really
felt it was trying to be that while also being
self-aware and tongue-in-cheek and having
that fun you know I think it was trying to
be at the qualities of of like a Sam Raimi
of the horror of Sam Raimi where where you
are this variety of qualities you know and
but it was but because the the journey like
I thought there was stuff planted like okay
yeah Nathan Fillion likes Elizabeth Banks
he has feelings probably in love with her
sure um but yeah there was there's something
about like you always need kind of a a little
bit more of a of a of an underlying motivation
or or more of a heart or something like that
to really connect to and I think that's what
James Gunn really really exceeds now you know
um and I think he's just become more refined
as that as a writer and a director so that
way you you remain as I noticed my emotional
investment was kind of dwindling towards the
end like the last 20 minutes I was like yeah
this is a short movie but I'm also ready to
call it yeah I found myself getting ready
to call it when when I noticed that when it
wasn't wrapped up in violence or practic or
crazy practical effects it was after um I
guess it was after the whole bug thing and
the and the and the girl we meet in the bathtub
with the family when it was mainly just becoming
like the crazies invasion of body snatcher
zombie or whatever you want to call it where
it's just mainly humans who are attacking
I was noticing my interest and it was actually
starting to dip yeah because it was picked
back up when it got to Michael Rooker and
monstrosity form yeah because it was less
interesting something like we can we're familiar
with so it wasn't like I don't know I think
the threat of like little worms are like a
giant worm person is more interesting than
watching a bunch of people like what you're
from like Creature Feature to zombie and like
yeah Creature Feature typically is more interesting
or even more scary than zombie but like but
I kind of agree with you I was never actually
scared during the movie I was more grossed
out yeah and kind of just like freaked out
but never like felt like I needed to like
truly cover my eyes like this is going to
keep me up at night kind of thing but I will
say that though the character work itself
wasn't the strongest I will say that the kind
of something we brought up while we're watching
the movie was the fact that the subtext of
like their characters relationships was there
without outright saying it like you can tell
that their relationship release that instance
from the night of their relationship between
Michael Rucker and Elizabeth Banks character
wasn't like the strongest she wasn't in the
mood and he was like frustrated by that kind
of implying that they've had these problems
before and then you saw like the connection
between Elizabeth Banks and Nathan fillings
character implying that this isn't their first
interaction before that they've had like denying
feelings for one another so I thought that
stuff was good but I think the the specificity
of like what makes these people these people
was kind of lacking also the girl in the third
act that was added at the house yeah she was
just kind of there and she literally only
served the point of uh Exposition and kind
of giving the characters uh knowledge into
where where these people are from because
I felt like James Gunn was like oh we need
an explanation for like where these people
came from uh she's gonna get a vision while
it's crawling their mouth she was the only
one who managed to pull it out yeah like uh
yeah I like the way they played with the I
like the sequences of violence a lot and like
I said everyone's good uh and I really mean
that like Nathan fillings really good Elizabeth
Banks I think is is really strong here too
yeah I think they elevate what was lacking
in the in the writing like Michael Rooker
is just the best reading one of them all and
and I love the way that I do like the way
how it factors into who he is as a character
prior to where when he just becomes a monster
he doesn't just only remain monster there's
like a Universal Studios monster movie tragic
quality about which I really like um and I
yeah yeah I mean I thought I was gonna repeat
myself yeah I guess that that's where I think
James Gunn has really excelled even more so
now is even just the personalities nowadays
even if there's like not much even if it's
not really about the depth you connect to
on a character the personalities you'll connect
with even more now uh with his writing so
I think even something like even like the
suicide squad which is like more jam-packed
with [__] I'm like oh I really cared about
everyone and by the end of that film you know
and here I'm like uh yeah I don't really I
don't really care about Nathan Fillion yeah
like he's fun he's like he's a good actor
he's a good even feeling yeah yeah exactly
like there's they have their moments where
they're really Charming but if he died I would
have been like all right yeah you know just
like how it was nothing how the uh the mayor
died like everybody who's a fun character
that he played that character very well but
then like he kind of died really quickly yeah
I didn't really care that much I think it's
funny I think uh there's there's a little
bit more oomph there's a little bit more um
uh boisterous qualities to I think the personalities
he does now where he knows how to make everyone
more unique and distinguishable not that these
characters weren't indistinguishable from
each other it's their the specificity of their
portrayals I think are stronger now but this
is him getting his feet wet this is gonna
be like his first movie you know so it is
kind of interesting to look back and you can
see the potential of like oh if we like if
we just watch this and I've seen his other
movies and be like oh you can see where he
could evolve as a filmmaker yeah and then
but Noah is now as a filmmaker like oh well
he's achieved that you know he's just gotten
better over the years but this is like a fun
B-movie thing that would like come on cable
or something like that and I think that's
sort of the vibe that it's aiming for right
off the bat like they established that tone
right away like that's what they're going
for they're not trying to be this this thing
with depth or something like that um but still
I think there was something there that could
have helped aided a tad bit more that way
I was because I I did find myself slightly
checking out towards the last like half hour
the last 20 minutes of this film I would say
I was like slightly checking out I'm like
and this is this is getting a little bit like
yeah you're going by the numbers you got to
fill out that movie run time I mean I thought
the thing with the grenade I expect them to
use that next supported that like there's
certainly yeah yeah yeah I thought things
were still working it got it got better that's
something I got better when I got back to
the the main hook which is the the monster
Michael Rooker like that's right talk about
that chunk like a little bit before that yeah
yeah I'm kind of bored now yeah we needed
a thing to get us from from A to B yeah yeah
I will say the biggest thing this movie did
for me though was make me want to see with
all the experiences and knowledge Jim Gunn
has now as a filmmaker what he would do with
a Slither today yeah to see like if you were
to make a Slither too how would he improve
about upon that because I imagine he had to
work here again where budgetary restraints
and all those things and you know and and
learning how to how to turn obstacles into
opportunities I'm sure this was a great Learning
lesson for all that too yeah so I think this
was 2005 so that was his like filmmaking feature
filmmaking debut yeah I think it's interesting
how kind of relating it back I guess to his
career overall so this is like a defining
film for him and his career and then like
on the 20-year anniversary of him becoming
a filmmaker he's like Dawning like Superman
like the yeah the hero of all heroes you know
so like I don't know I'm excited to see his
his Evolution as a filmmaker oh yeah sounds
like another bringing his his careers had
like Milestones I would say and let's see
like what the next big milestone is with with
something like a Superman it being 20 years
removed from this movie yeah now he clearly
loves this genre too of this kind of horror
uh you could see those sprinkled in a lot
of his work even today he's into fleshy things
oh yeah he provides it especially sci-fi horror
I think he's really Dr like he doesn't strike
him as a supernatural horror kind of guy but
sci-fi even though there you get those some
of those homages there here um sci-fi horror
it seems very apparent he's very drawn of
that you've seen it in the suicide squad with
stuff like starro and whatever yeah you know
um a lot of the uh dark twisted humor the
tragedy of stuff with like the mom of of uh
of polka dot man in there and then you could
see the horror in Guardians 3 as well yeah
a lot of that weird sexual deviousness in
in Guardians too with ego a lot of the horrors
really placed throughout in uh I would say
uh Peacemaker too like there's a lot of this
I was like a lot of this is reminding me of
what I saw in Peacemaker yeah a lot of this
kind of went back to that that lower budget
route with Peacemaker in that show yeah yeah
yeah and small town and Hive mine monster
yeah totally totally yeah and um so I I and
and like the southern personalities to you
know there's a lot of that that I was definitely
picking up on uh but yeah I mean other than
just comparing it because I feel like we were
pointing out everything we liked about it
uh through throughout the experience of watching
the movie yeah I feel like we were already
pointing along I do and I like that I do like
the music and everything and I so uh yeah
this is an enjoyable film it was fun it was
it was a really it was a really fun one and
so there's some images here that are just
that were really just really disturbing yeah
that almost never happens to me where my stomach
starts to be like Oh I'm getting a bit of
a of a nausea feeling right now and I rarely
ever have that happen to me but yeah that
was really stomach churning at a couple of
points um but yeah I think it's just a little
bit of a little bit of character fleshing
out and a little bit of uh I don't know something
with the umph of the editing I think in a
certain chunk would have helped I feel like
they never took its foot off the pedal but
for the most part really fun film once again
around Tomatoes then we'll call it a day what's
the Rotten Tomatoes score let's see let me
see I'm gonna guess I'm gonna guess is 60.
I guess a 75. all right wow 87 way off here
wow critics loved it audiences audiences were
that I was closer with the audience audience
score is 63 percent and then uh audience uh
critic score is 87 slimy B movie homage yes
definitely affecting low budget horror films
creepy and funny if you've got the stomach
that's pretty much everything we said all
we got to do is read a Ron Spanish feel like
yeah yeah let's just uh go off of that copy
that yeah
yeah it was close I was way off I was really
close to the audience those people critics
really loved it yeah alrighty guys well thank
you so much for being here we'll see you all
soon thank you Aaron and share us on patreon
as well peace out
foreign